bon il ya ding je crois que vous avez 31
ans oui vous avez appris le français
elle je vais avoir à prendre je
commençais à apprendre le français à
l'âge de 20 ans 20 ans oui pourquoi ne
l'avez vous pas appris avant avant
j'étais j'ai pas pu apprendre parce
qu'avant j'étais présent j'étais à la
cabane et j'ai suivi mon père travaille
et étanche dans les champs et alors vous
avez donc appris le français il ya onze
ans il ya dix ans avec il ya dix ans
vous avez trouvé le temps d'écrire de
traduire en chinois quelques ouvrages de
sartre de baudelaire de sait plus qui de
canut etc
mais c'est quand même formidable parce
que le français m'a passionne d'abord et
enchaîner on travaille beaucoup mais je
crois que si j'étais en france j'ai été
en france
je n'aurais pas pu travailler autant
parce que il est adepte a fait il ya des
soirées comme ça là bas c'est tout est
fermé
après 10 heures après après après 7
heures
bah alors pour la méditation aux normes
à l'horizon que travail travail est bon
de préseau c'est en quelque sorte de 0 c
on a aussi le plaisir d'être présent par
exemple je pourrais travailler comme ça
je pourrais très dur et je crois que en
plongeant dans ses oeuvres françaises
qui sont tellement passionnant et
fascinante et j'ai trouvé aux jo j'ai
trouvé aussi un grand plaisir
oui vous avez l'esprit d'un véritable
amour pour notre langue
oui parce que j'aime bien parler j'aime
bien écrire écrire pour moi en français
c'est plutôt chercher paris voyait dans
cette grande salle et vous tapez vous
avez déjà dire puisque vous venez
souvent on dit la sortie est là et 11%
dire sans réfléchir ou prenez ce sordide
mais pour moi je sais qu'il existe
vaguement une sortie quelque part et
donc je dois ouvrir
je dois chercher à ouvrir tous les
placards pour chercher enfin une sortie
dans la bonne soeur dit est toujours là
peut-être je découvrais quelque chose
que vous n'aurez plus jamais été
recouvrés et jolie métaphore
voilà j'aime bien j'aime bien ce travail
claude hagège vous qui maniait je ne
sais combien de langues notamment le
chinois tient pour il veut dire que le
pcc le féliciter le quand-même méritent
d'être félicités pellucide chinois qu'on
entende un peu cette langue inuit
tu sais toi et c'est in the days que il
te le diras tu te mentir ces bourses
c'est pour tester si je suis frais
chinois ou pas bon la raison c'est que
si vous aviez restaurant vietnamien
il m'arrive de parler en chinois pour
voir on me répond en vietnamien par
conséquent c'est un test mais il répond
aux chinois et yapo chinois bons repères
vraiment quand une performance
formidable en disant l'événement ouais
c'est quand même
non parce que d'écrire ce roman bon
alors vous l'écris bella pourquoi avez
vous écrit en français finalement pas
qu'est ce qu'il ne faut pas faire pour
moi je suis du pain français
vous vivez en france oui depuis un an et
demi
ah bon mais vous allez rester en france
je passe je sais pas donc je vous ennuie
pas de nouvel outil francs j'essaie de
rester non parce que j'ai écrit en
français d'abord sérieusement ce livre
j'ai d'écrire en français parce que
c'est parce que je trouve que d'abord la
aime beaucoup la langue française et
deuxièmement écrivant en français ce
livre ça me donne une liberté
ça me donne une liberté d'abord sur le
thème de mon livre parce que ça parle le
livre parle de la cette époque qu'ils
sont
horrible pour nous la révolution
culturelle à la révolution culturelle et
donc le roman à travers son regard des
enfants ça peut être sympa ça peut être
très négatif très très c'est à vous de
me dire vous avez le goût des livres
deuxièmement pourquoi j'ai écrit en
français parce que j'écris en français
et que écrivent en français ça me tenait
aussi à une atmosphère en france plus
littéraire par exemple aujourd'hui je
suis venu discuter avec vous avec tous
les grands écrivains comme ça et c'est
une possibilité pour moi t'enrichir pas
dans l'autre sens c'est en tentant dans
le frêle dans la ferai littérature dans
des accidents
si j'étais enchaîné j'ai publié un livre
en chine la discussion sera porté sur la
politique sur les directives du parti il
faut chanter les louanges et comme moi
je
j'aime bien écrire et tout ça et tout
cela bon finalement la ligne pour dire
la ferai réseau pour collection sans
cesse c'est pour apprendre le français
j'ai bien écouté alors ce que vous savez
bien parce que déjà écrit un roman de
250 pages directement en français mais
j'écris aussi avec beaucoup de
difficultés oui je fais mon tour j'ai
passé un temps fou à chercher des mots
qui n'existent pas sur tout voyez j'ai
été dix cas serrée et le livre mais de
cheryl amis français c'est que eux qui
m'ont je pourrais dire sans eux je
n'aurais pas il n'y aura pas eu le livre
parce que c'est moi j'ai travaillé chez
eux je suis au doigt joël nodin et puis
qui mate qui m'a abordée au moment où le
pire moment cette personne ne croyait
que je pourrais faire un livre en
français même moi je croyais pas est-ce
que je peux écrire un livre en français
je peux pas alors personne ne croyait
les éditeurs ne croyait pas tous mes
amis avec qui je voulais travailler
m'apprendre au son parti bons sont
empêchés par le temps et puis il ya une
seule personne qui a cru c'est joël qui
m'a beaucoup aidé et qui est tout ça
c'est comme ça que c'est plutôt c'est
aussi une collaboration ou entre
équipiers de fait décrire comme occasion
d'apprendre le français rappelle ce que
font les instituteurs qui apprennent
alors l'orthographe en enseignant est ce
que disait un écrivain visible cercles
que la meilleure façon là et deux aides
dans des pays qu'on désire visiter ces
dexia sur ces pays puis on se procure
des moyens d'aller voir évidemment on
écrit dessus sans avoir jamais été alors
un mot sur le sur la sur l'histoire vous
raconter c'est un enfant de neuf ans et
s'appelle yang je crois et qui va la
campagne avec son père qui est nommé
préfet pendant la révolution culturelle
il arrive dans un village où il découvre
le monde paysan qui ne connaît pas voilà
et c'est le choc entre la politique buy
list
et puis c'est ce qu'on appelle et des
superstitions qui sont qui estime qu'ils
sont représentés par une église avec une
construite d'ailleurs par des français
et avec une croix dessus de l'église
oui c'est ça parce que la chine ton vous
comme un don dont parle et vous
connaissez c'est toujours le confucius
l'otan estime et tourner l'histoire que
vous citez je considère que c'est une il
ya de chine
la chine est donc ton parler surtout ici
même en ville en chine parmi les
intellectuels c'est la chine de surface
c'est à dire c'est comme manche la chine
a une à une telle a une histoire un peu
diffus différentes
c'est à dire il y a le monde telle est
très là on parle dans une langue on
écrit dans une langue est ce à ce qu'on
connaisse plus tôt le montre de le monde
de laiterie tandis que la plupart des
chinois sont des paysans sont des
illettrés
ils lisent jamais peut pas lire et
lisent jamais ce qu'ils on écrire comme
l'instance de confucius si vous allez
dans un village où vécut toute une vie
confucius a tellement connu en france
apparaît et eux ils ignorent totalement
donc c'est d'une autre chine que j'ai
découvre et plus savoureux parce que
plus profond c'est la fraîche chine
parce que pourquoi je dis c'est la vraie
chine parce que c'était plus des
milliers de milliers d années des
coutumes des moeurs des rites transmis
du père o'sheas avec des pleins des
dictons parce que ça façonne plein de
petits couteaux et je peux j'aimerais
aussi dire que la la la première chine
vient de la deuxième chez et voyons
c'est un dans lequel j'ai déjà écrit
en pratique on a une confiance on a en
pratique c'est pas une sorte de religion
c'est plutôt au tout au long de
l'histoire
on a compris quelque chose qu'on n'aura
pas vu comprendre sans vivre dans cette
terre par exemple la voie de la terre là
j'ai vraiment entendu j'ai frères
entendu et tout le monde trouve que
c'est normal c'était quelqu'un qui
cherche à saper cherche à savoir ont
trouvé que vous êtes ridicules alors il
faut dire que yang va 9 ans va être
devenir une sorte d'adeptes de la
révolution culturelle bien entendu parce
qu'il est pris par le mouvement jusqu'au
jour il va s'apercevoir qu'il en est que
sa famille et lui en sont les victimes
voirie un retournement mais entendu de
l'histoire on a des témoignages des
autres de ce qui s'est passé en chine à
cette époque et que des livres qui sont
parus mais c'est tout à fait intéressant
pour nous racontiez avec un roman c'est
un con c'est un roman mais à lille il y
avait les électeurs qui m'ont proposé tu
écris un témoignage mais ont refusé
oui et même si la décision qui me
demandaient de changer le personnage en
première tombe comme ça pour que ça
saisissent plus les gens finalement j'ai
refusé parce que je trouve que bon c'est
vrai en france on s'intéresse beaucoup à
la chine on s'adresse vous la chine mais
je remarque c'est que tout le temps
l'année rake en effet la main entendu un
gant parce que bon il ya beaucoup de
livres il parle d'un chai ne sachant des
documentaires des témoignages qu'on a
qu'on a écrit après 3 ou de trois
semaines ou un mois de voyage en chine
y'at-il c'est utile tous ses vivres
moi je n'ai pas lu le livre mais j'ai eu
des conversations avec des gens qui ont
lu ses livres
et puis j'ai trouvé et j'ai constaté
combien mal dans des camps alors j'ai
réfléchi je me suis dit écrire un roman
c'est différent et lire un roman c'est
différent de livres un des tops des
documents s'ils ont des documents aura
cru ce que ce qu'on fait ce qu'on ne
s'était nos arrive alors on apprend
toujours à distance tandis qu'un roman
je l'écris avec une sensation ça vous
permet de travailler dans une sensation
et les lecteurs en lisant le roman il
vit avec le personnage
il croit que c'est une façon je ne t'ai
pas la meilleure c'est une façon de
connaître ces thèmes en libye a dit ou
écrit document vous ne seriez pas
aujourd'hui sur la liste des
goncourables des colonies
amos